so I'll let you introduce it as we clap
you onto the stage please welcome
Gabrielle but yeah so basically can you
hear me do I need to speak by the I need
to speak them okay so I can't walk
around stage all right so obviously with
storytelling organizations so we're
going to give you a story in two seasons
the first season is all about
introducing the business problem that
we've been trying to solve and how we
used a what we call a focus product in
order to build a machine learning
capability around inside of the BBC and
there's going to be four episodes it's
going to be directed by me and after
that Douglas is going to follow up with
that and actually since this is PI data
we thought we probably should talk to
you a little bit about Python and little
bit about technology so we will revisit
some of the themes and Douglas will be
able to tell you MIT bit more about okay
so what did we actually do and why did
we do what we did all right
perfect so quickly an introduction to
myself and I'm Gabrielle I've been now
with the BBC since summer last year
originally I studied mathematics in
Cambridge I worked as a management
consulting for a couple of years and
came back to the UK and did an MBA
London Business School I then set up and
ran Tesco's data science team for a
couple of years after I became the data
director and not in the high street and
joined the BBC about yeah 15 months ago
or something I am Jenny my job is to
come into organisations and kind of help
them make better use out of their data
and machine learning assets so I'll sort
of they dated usually by using some sort
of machine learning and so generally
what that involves is that I come into
an organization I need to build new
capability and then I get kind of all of
these different parts of the
organization that tell me what they
expect from machine learning right so
you have your marketing team if your
finance team if your technology team and
they all have these expectations around
what data and data science can do for
them and not rarely some of that
expectation at least is based out of
some shiny marketing material that a big
technology company has put in front of
some c-level executive and you know a
lot of my
Jaffer's managing expectations and
trying to figure out how do you actually
get on that journey and this is the
third time or full-time that I'm doing
this so kind of what I'm taking you
through this is kind of the last
iteration of an approach of how to bring
an organizational to that journey and
we're not no when done with this so I'm
sure there's going to be a whole bunch
of stuff that we haven't figured out yet
that's going to go wrong that maybe some
of the stuff that we've been learning so
far and that kind of has worked we'll
give you some better perception of how
when you find yourself in a situation
where you basically are brought into an
organization and get us okay make more
out of the data we have or just do
something with machine learning it might
give you some ideas of how you can start
on that journey
so the first episode is journeying into
the center of the TARDIS and actually
it's really interesting so Wendy when
you get into an organization and you
kind of have a certain perception of
what the problem space is like from the
outside Jenny when you then get into the
inside you realize holy [ __ ] this
problem is much much bigger than when we
look like from the outside and if you're
the person who gets brought in and
you're also sunny also the person was
expected to know how to fly this thing
even though you've it's the first time
that you've actually seen the buttons
and so this is kind of what happened to
me and the chief architect has started
this idea around we need to do something
about data a bit more in the BBC he had
created a program called connected data
he had also managed to convince the
organisation that actually there were
problem spaces and probably around three
areas how we could bunch of data so
audience data content data and partner
data audience data is something that we
had already been working on so that was
kind of under control I came in and I
was like okay now sort out content data
and in order to help you understand why
that is hard I thought I'd give you like
different like introduction into the BBC
so we kind of invented radio in 1922 we
then kind of invented TV in the 30s
every time we did this and every time a
new technology came around basically
what we end up doing is building a new
technology team to look after that so
when terracotta TV came around that kind
of was close enough to TV similarly with
televised news weather and Olympics
Ceefax is our version of teletext so the
ability to read some
on top of you TV BBC micro might have
been something that you guys I don't
know how old you are I'm not trying but
you know maybe that was the first ways
then you got introduced to programming
so you kind of see that the BBC has had
a very very diverse technology stack
it's been around for about 100 years
there's 20,000 people working in this
organization so whenever you bring
someone in you sell them okay tell them
all right now start figuring out data
you can probably appreciate that is
quite a big challenge there's a lot of
data silos in this some of these data
silos are based on culture until about
three years ago we actually had three
different technology organizations one
was looking after the television and
video one was looking after our
commercial arm and one was looking after
the online space also when I was
interviewing and asked what kind of
technology do you use the answer was
everything and since I've joined I can
probably confirm that we've using
everything so there's a whole bunch of
problems that you have in this
organization that you need to start
figuring out and I said the site benefit
I had was I had a boss who had already
brought in and said okay we have a data
problem he then said okay Gabrielle is
now gonna come and he's gonna sort this
out and then on my third day I had to
make decisions around what are we
actually gonna do we developed this idea
of a Content graph that was gonna sit in
the middle and create kind of bring all
that content together it was if I'm
honest and still is it's partly a
marketing thing because people will have
heard of social graph from Facebook and
the north' graph of Google so they have
a bit of a sense of it's probably good
other tech companies do that it's not
necessarily a way that we were going to
implement it so it's not necessary that
now we're building everything on top of
a graph database but it does represent
that we care about individual piece of
content we care about relationships
because we believe that what the BBC is
all about or should be all about is
about bringing you the best content
given what you interested in if you
navigate the website today you kind of
have to understand our log structure you
need to understand that news is here and
reports in two different director
therefore on the hierarchy is somewhere
else then iPlayer because that's a
different game that doesn't really make
sense
we believe that audiences today actually
want something where the best content
gets pushed to them in a much much
easier way so how do you tackle that
what we end up doing our kind of our
approach was okay actually we think
there's probably three prototypes that
we should
building and this was the decision I
made on day three so you know in
retrospect it kind of probably okay but
so we end up deciding to build three
prototypes one was around creating a
personal app for people commuting the
idea was he really can we bring the best
of the BBC content into one place and
serve it to people in a format that
makes sense to their media consumption
opportunity
the second was around building a tool
that helps optimize schedules across
multiple TV channels one of the things
that lots of people don't realize who
don't work for the BBC is that we have a
whole bunch of teams who don't own a
channel right so we have something like
arts they need to coordinate some stuff
on bbc1 then BBC Two's and they have
social media inside of it and it needs
to go on iPlayer so it's actually is
surprisingly complicated optimization
problem also because we're a public
service organization there's a whole
bunch of things that we need to satisfy
so there's a certain amount of our stuff
we need to produce in heavy UK region we
need to represent the diversity of the
UK public and interests etc etcetera so
actually it becomes surprisingly
complicated but all of this really is
only possible if we understand our
content so the third thing that we ended
up building was what we called kind of
meta to Saurus Rex which was all about
how do we best attack the content that
we have what all of these had in common
was they were all built on this idea of
a content graph in the center all of the
tools would enhance I graph the
understanding of the content and they
were all using a bunch of machine
learning and you might say wow that's
really expensive way of doing
stakeholder management and because
actually we spent a whole bunch of money
to build this none of this code was
reusable we didn't really show it to any
proper audiences and I probably agree
with you but the BBC is a narrative
organization for us the smallest unit is
the story and it's really really
important to have something where you
show ok this is where we're going to go
this is why it has to be something that
is more than a conceptual idea it has to
be kind of props etc and so these three
things gave us the props that we were
able to take to our deputy director
general and to our chief technology and
product officer to agree the next steps
forward and this was about the first
three months or so of of my time there
and after that was all about creating
really what are we going to do now with
these props how are you gonna take any
of this forward and what we agreed was
actually
if we're going to build a platform that
brings together better data and takes
advantage of machine learning what we
need is a way to get to an audience
because if you don't have an audience
then there's no real point in building
this because you end up either in one
hand where you build a platform that
kind of tries to boil the ocean and I've
showed you beforehand what data problems
we have across the organization all
right is this thing that kind of
basically gets stranded because there's
no way to get to an audience so
therefore you have no way to test your
propriety cessation and you have no way
to test your machine learning algorithms
and so what we did is we agreed with our
chief technology product and product
officer and our deputy director general
that we were going to basically create a
focus product and this focus product was
going to be a audience racing product it
was going to be completely different to
anything the BBC had so far and it was
really gonna drive all of the
prioritization for the rest of our work
and that gave us now enough information
to start hiring people with the right
skill sets and we initially hired a
product manager for their focus product
together with him we xx go okay what is
it really that this product is going to
do and and there were four kind of key
things that we wanted to product to do
one was it was going to be aimed at 16
to 34 year olds mostly because all of
the customer research we had we knew
that the parents of that generation have
much more affinity with the BBC than
that generation itself given that we
knew that this was going to be the
generation we were gonna aim at it was
relatively obvious that we were going to
build a personalized mobile app because
those people are very mobile centric
they care about the apps and we also
know that they care a lot about
short-form video okay so we were going
to build something with short form video
it has the additional benefits that
actually creating recommendations for
short phone videos easier than for
long-form video the reason for that
being is because actually if you put
something in front of someone which is
short form you're only really asking
them to invest about seven minutes
rather than 45 minutes so if you get a
bit wrong they're more likely to still
stay with you and then it's also
technology decision that actually for us
building short form is simpler because
we have a simple way of rendering videos
in
on mobile devices we don't have the same
approach for articles so we still have
multiple ways of doing articles there's
no single vendor once that we figure all
of that stuff out CBC's Jeni known for
being an update organization so if I
look at most of you you probably mostly
go to the BBC probably tomorrow morning
at 6 o'clock you're gonna wake up you're
gonna open the BBC app and you're gonna
see what happens in the US midterm
elections that's kind of the way that
the BBC is generally perceived as an
update app it's not an app to help you
kind of spend you a better time so it's
quite an unemotional relationship with
our customers so what we want to do with
our app is to be slightly different and
kind of focused really about helping you
spend your spare moments in the best way
it also means that slightly easier from
an editorial perspective for us and I'll
talk a bit more about it or later so
that was agreed we started building the
team out a bit more at that point we
then started building the architecture
for the platform in parallel to kind of
UX designs and what we really quickly
realized is actually the power of what
we're gonna do is that we bring together
three things we bring together our
editorial knowledge so what we've been
doing for a hundred years that probably
no one can compete with none of the
Facebook's or the googles is we've been
telling stories in kind of sequences
right we've been building TV schedules
we've been creating editorial lists of
articles on something so that was going
to be key our app was going to be only
different if we bring an editorial the
best of the BBC's content and the
interest stuff of the kind of the
audience what they tell us about the
interests and our yaks team that
basically developed a what we call like
the fin slice or the Minimum Viable
Product of what we needed to be to
support in order to do that so we needed
a login page luckily we can use BBC
sign-in so once the app is available you
can just use your BBC account that will
pull in some data that we already have
about you then there is a home page that
basically creates the personalised
stream for you anything you've already
watched will not be included in there
once you watch any of the video clips
and there's related content underneath
there's a history page because we
actually care about transparency so we
want to tell you how we've created this
personalized dream for you in the front
page so the history stream as soon as
you've watched something will appear
there and then there was some simple
error messaging as well and that
actually get got us into the first
problem and I'm not going to talk a lot
about this because and
Douglas is gonna talk a lot more about
this but gently how do you start
building a recommendation well there's
kind of two ways you can do a
content-based or user based given that
we had never done this with this kind of
content we didn't really have a lot of
good content metadata and we didn't mean
you have a lot of user interaction
history I'm not going to tell you what
we did because that will be Douglas as
part but you know think about that
problem how do you guys start in this
case all right so we are in an
organization that does that has a lot of
data
lots of messy places doesn't mean you
know what to do with it how do you move
this forward over and over again you're
going to fall into some of these
challenges this was actually one of the
reasons why we want to focus product
because now we could show actually this
is not just a problem that's out there
it's an actual problem that we need to
solve and what we ended building is we
end up building a internal prototype and
to test with internal audiences because
actually it's hard to figure out whether
it's good enough it's hard to figure out
whether enough of our content goes
through and that was really interesting
because it showed us another interesting
problem that is quite distinct to the
BBC OSS listing to a media organization
and you don't have a few platforms such
as Facebook or Google it is that we're
actually legally liable about what we
put out this is because we're not just a
distributor but we also come to producer
and it's just two things two challenges
that we're working for at the moment and
I think we've mostly cracked how we we
deal with that from machine learning
perspective the first thing is about
defamation so most of the videos that we
tend to show on our web sites there is
an article embed around them that allows
you to kind of just clarify some of the
statements you're making it allows you
to bring out other opinions in our case
when it's just a short form video
proposition we don't have that ability
so we need to find different ways to let
people know that they feel that we're
not representing the fairness and kind
of impartiality of our editorial values
and the second thing is around contempt
of court which is the problem that
actually if someone for example is
currently being accused of sexual
harassment and we have an interview with
that person denying claims a great
content or content recommendation engine
we'll have lots of related content
underneath which talks about sexual
harassment if that happens why the court
causes the court cases happening that
might be perceived as us having having
an opinion about the guilt of that
person and actually this is the first
time ever in my life that I had
discussions with people around who's
going to go to prison if we get
editorial sorry forget product or
decisions wrong this is where I'm going
to hand over to Douglas to tell you a
bit more about actually what did I mean
for us in practice and how do we build
somewhere from technology perspective so
hi everyone
my name is Douglas I just saw a quick
introduction so I was born in Brazil and
originally I was a mechanical
aeronautical engineer and but I've been
working with data science since then but
we didn't have a name at the time and
I've brought come today okay three years
ago so before the body CEO was working
in the mirror as well so I have them to
build our data science thing and choose
to just something very similar what
we're doing here in BBC and I've
recently joined BBC three months ago
yeah thing beginning of all of us so
that's me
so just you two in mind we're gonna we
don't have too many data in terms of the
quality of the metadata because when you
take a look on the content that we have
there are a lot of missing gaps we have
a lot of missing features there so how
can we build recommendations on that and
also about the user because we don't
have the user base to start building our
things so this leads us to our first
channel so if we want to for instance to
build a recommendation says it's not
something like that so one of the
challenges is to get the user data so if
we cannot put our hands on having a user
data on our hands how it can be the
collaborative filtering how we can
understand which content is more valid
for the user or not and so we are that
we have that in our hands
but we need to move forward so the quick
wings when you have a situation like
that is to try to go for the things that
have a higher impact so for instance the
data that we have if we have something
that has a missing genre or a missing
Brown that's something that we can try
to infer based on the I on the clips on
where the video is so we can look for
the parent of that video we can look for
its siblings to try to identify okay I
think this video here is something
related to music or is related to arts
and festivals and then with that you
have a much
broader data set that you can use to
provide recommendations to the user so
just as an example when we started from
our recommendation engine I think we had
around five to ten percent of our
content that was available to use but
after we use this enrichment pipeline
the just the beginning of it
we jump into something around 80 and 90
percent of our our video content so and
the same thing about the videos about
their user data so if you think about
the user data we don't have access for
the very recent user data that there's a
process to get that but we have access
we can have access for people's data set
not near your time users okay so what
can we build it that and this leads us
for our initial recommender system that
would be something that is trying to
mimic the user behavior so how we work
on that when you think about the BBC app
that we have also our user logs in and
he goes into our app we can ask for our
assistance if the user has any watch
history what he lacked before loved
favorite and so on and we can use this
information to create a histogram of the
user so based on this histogram we query
our content graph with here our data and
to provide and then we provide back to
the app some recommendations for the
user so with this this first
recommendation engine is more like a
search engine and we're trying to get
the data and to filter and to put into
but that's what the user like so for
instance if you like more music there
will be more music videos in your screen
if you like more sports will be more
sporting screen but also we add out a
bit of randomization to that so it
doesn't get boring so it not just seeing
the same thing over and over and you're
able to explore the whole BBC content
it's fast
it's something that we could create in a
couple of sprints but it's it's what I
what I most like about it is that we can
use this as a cold start we can try to
create like a understandable
user that we can converse with editorial
team and okay this is what we're gonna
show them also on this initial part we
started working with some
experimentation so before we release the
app it's important to have this set up
we're using service sign to recommend an
experimentation engine and the way we've
done this is just using decorators on
the parts that we're trying to
experiment so for instance if we're on
the home screen if we're running one of
the experiments there we just pass the
token about the experiment that we're
running if you want this for and we can
understand more about the user who's the
user with the handle token
authentication so it's basically goes
into the request gets all the
information that we want and enables for
the function that we're using at the
time so we can reuse this piece of code
in many different places and make it
easier for people to try to experiment
things so what are the main
characteristics that we found about this
initial and simple recommender system
first it can learn what the user likes
to watch very easily so people that are
using it
oh yeah it's kind of showing me what I
used to like so yeah when I go in the
morning and try to look it's showing
what I what I what I like and it was
users to explore all of the busy clips
in a simple way it was fast to Butte but
some caveats the items sometimes are
quite random remember that we don't have
the user data we don't know what's
important we don't know what's popular
we cannot compare them so this is an
issue and we have to fix that for next
interations so that will not be that of
course and if the content is not well
mixed it can include the users in a
bubble so if you're just watching
sporting it's part Aida's if you don't
do it properly it will be just support
articles for you which leads us for our
next recommendation system that is a
simple collaborative filtering around
around the data that we have so what is
collaborative filtering for for those
who are not familiar is basically trying
to find your doppelganger and trying to
say okay which one
in our database has similar tastes with
you and then we try to provide to you
what those persons have seen in watch as
well so how we did it basically we use
two data sources to provide some to
train the models and we created
playlists based on them so we use it the
data from the users and we also uses
some created lists from the journalists
so what we did with that we created with
that list we were trying to understand
whenever someone watched a video what
were the related videos that were around
that play so with this you can do this
with within the whole user database with
with within the whole playlist and try
to okay whenever someone watches a
particular clip for instance brexit
these are the possible videos that we
will be showing to that person and it
works really well it's very similar to
the it's using the word vector model so
and whenever we need to to infer this we
separate two parts of the user history
so on the initial part we build a user
history and based on that user history
we try to predict what the user is
trying to see and one particularly
important about this one is that with
tests on unseen users so the model is
stronger on that part just for
clarification just to see how it would
look like I remove it a lot of our code
there just included one of the main bits
and you can see that is there a very
simple structure we just get the data
set we created a class to try to load
this from our servers and then we split
it into training validation and test and
then after that we pass this to a model
and do a great search to try to see the
hyper parameters and saving the best
model for that so also we have that we
can start serving this either in memory
or either putting this this vectors in a
database so this is more about this
collaborative filtering
leads to our next steps so also we have
this into production because it's almost
the end of the year we're gonna try to
explore new entries so phrases for the
beginning of next year we're trying to
merge the collaborative filtering that
we created today with content data as
well because if we have that it will be
much better to try to solve the
cold-start problem for content-based
recommendations also we want to
implement speech to tax on our clips to
understand what's there in terms of
content and apply different techniques
to extract some entities from that and
for most of our clips there are no
subtitles but for for the ones that we
don't have we can use that we also want
to use tools that we've building housed
for image recognition to understand who
is on the steps to do that fine-tuning
about the recommendations on what to
show to someone and also to apply and do
many many types of different feature
extractions including the tax that we
already have to be able to connect this
those solutions with new so for instance
if you have something video can we
provide a news that is related to that
so this is one of the questions that we
have as well so thank you and if you'd
like to work for us we're hiring so
please talk with us after after the top
and also we actually run a BBC machine
learning fireside chat meetup as well
which the next event is on the 21st of
November where we tend to talk a lot
about the strategic and ethical
implications of machine learning so just
check us out and meet up it gives you
another opportunity to kind of interact
with our teams and figure out whether
this is of interest to you
thank you very much and you kept
beautifully to time so supportive
erasing a bit no you were like rush to a
little bit but you completely captain
brilliant which means we have time for a
good break in a little while when we're
done with questions
I think cherry is already here diving in
with a question just before you ask it
the fireside chats I presume you're
gonna link those in the comments again
to the Meetup well if you go to find out
how they feel that they have the right
they also linked on there and I guess
when I do the email out to everyone I
should link there as well
cherry please yes actually this is very
interesting thank you very much and I
see that you have the recommendation
system which is using multimedia things
use image or use the you know the text
do you think that would apply to dating
out as well to dating apps I think it I
think it's a fire boss but yeah you can
use this for dating apps yeah definitely
yes we communication yes so I think one
of the interesting things for us was
always what's the right histogram to
build right so what are those categories
that we want to put stuff into you
probably have something similar around
the dating apps where actually am I
always looking at a certain type of age
or whatever that you know you have to be
careful so one of the things that
Douglas mentioned is you have to be
careful to not get people into a bubble
right so one of the things that we have
in our case is we have an editorial
person embedded in our team that makes
sure that you don't just watch sports so
we do certain things with our histograms
that if we notice that you're getting
into a bubble we open up your horizon
again and I would suggest strongly given
your dating that you do something
similar because you might get into
dangerous territory otherwise I think so
I was wondering do you do any particular
modeling to account for a change in the
users preferences over time good
question so we we try to experiment with
the window size for what we're trying to
do here so we notice that depending on
the window it doesn't really change the
outcomes of the model so and the lower
the lower the window the better the
results and I think it kind of reflects
how people use the app so for instance
if you're looking for a particular set
of news you won't be browsing into
infinity just oh I want to look for this
thing and then you just look at that
so yes so we don't we didn't do many
research in that area
but I think we're gonna do that whenever
it's hard to to model sequence models to
check this following on from the
question about breaking people out of
these bubbles of recommendations and
mentioned you had an editorial person on
the team so presumably this wasn't done
in a random way so how did you compete
how do you manage competing interests
within the organization from the
incredible power that some would have
from steering but a different yeah and
so by having one editorial person in our
team so the way we structured in a way
is we have a product manager for the app
an editorial person in the team and we
have a product manager for the platform
as well so that kind of gives free
people that are responsible for stuff or
actually be two people and they have
very clearly defined stuff so the
product manager for the app in yen has
to define decide what the app looks like
product manager for the platform is
responsible for the machine learning
algorithms to a certain extent as well
the editorial person is the one that we
need to convince to get a or a sign-off
for but it's a lot of back and forth so
one of the things that we had a lot of
discussions for example was like there's
opinions around what good content looks
like so first she said actually if it's
less than three three words in the title
it's a bad title exclude all of that
stuff now by being embed in our team we
can then go back and we can get one of
the day's signs to say actually if you
do that you exclude 50% of the content
do you really want to do that and this
was a bit of a back-and-forth by having
one person door it means that she can
channel all of the rest of the editorial
discussions with the rest of the BBC and
she can also do that selling part which
is just as important right so other
editorial colleagues are much more
likely to listen to her if she says okay
this is under control don't be worried
then if I would go there because what do
I know about a journal so it's actually
it helps having just one person that
really helped us I'm gonna say one more
question I think because I can imagine
there's a rich conversation to go on
actually carry on in the break afterward
so bumble BBC iPlayer and why you're
creating a new app instead of using that
because I first ins use BBC iPlayer and
it was wondering first of all do you
take any of the history from BBC iPlayer
to this new app your moisture strategy
around this new up and is this
particularly why for instance I've had
now I have to sign it BBC iPlayer to use
it is this part of your strategies so
the reason you have to sign into VP
iPlayer is not related to this so this
is really to the last charter where the
government kind of made us promise that
we'll make sure that you pay your
licence
no so is it slightly separated to that
so the iPlayer is at the moment very
much a product that allows you to enjoy
long-form dramas etc it's not the thing
that you pick up when you have ten or
fifteen minutes in between while you're
going to waiting for the tube for
example or waiting for a bus generally
and that's kind of what this app is is
focus on something very different so
actually we have about a million clips
or something like that that do not
appear on iPlayer they appear on the
pages of a news article for example or
they appear as part of the sports
section or they appear because they're
basically a trailer to some episode that
we're creating so it brings together all
of these short form clips to try and
kind of bring the best of the you know
it's really to get help you better spend
your short amounts of times it's not
there in order to replace iPlayer
there's interesting questions over just
a quick one were we able to use any of
the iPlayer data actually we've tried
that we try to create histograms based
on your I play history to see whether we
could create short form it's just quite
different and we didn't realize I was
actually adding that much value what
we're trying to do however see whatever
we build from an algorithmic perspective
to what extent can we then bringing our
back to iPlayer so that actually the
experience for you is much more similar
when you navigate across the different
BBC projects in the future let's thank
our speakers
[Applause]